[Music]
hey what is up guys mkvhd here and fun
fact my second most viewed video of all
of the past year was the one that i made
about this guy the xiaomi me mix that
video got a lot of attention in fact a
lot of you guys were asking about it
since it's been about a year if there
would be some kind of a follow-up or a
sequel to that
and there is
and this is it this is the xiaomi me mix
2. you see the thing about the original
meme mix was as beautiful and awesome as
it showed up on video i don't know if
that really directly translated to sales
i mean at the end of the day this is
still a pretty huge unwieldy phone for a
lot of people it's still running a rom
that's pretty unfamiliar to a lot of
people that aren't in those asian
markets so even though it did have an
awesome super thin bezel suite form
factor that helped move the needle for
the entire smartphone industry like we
see in 2017
people weren't exactly rushing to uh
import this into the us and buy it and
actually make it their daily driver so
that's where me mix 2 comes in so pretty
much every single change that xiaomi
made from the mix 1 to the mix 2 is to
make this a more approachable more
viable sequel to the phone that made
such an impact for them last year so
right off the bat the mix 2 is smaller
so it's rocking a 6 inch oled display
but of course keeping the signature tiny
front and side bezels so it's a huge
display about the same size as the new
iphone we're about to see you know 5.8
to 6 inches but of course in a footprint
that's way smaller and easier to grip
even with one hand and the six inch
display even though it sounds big for a
phone it's in that tall narrow two to
one aspect ratio so it's going to be
easier to reach the size on the corners
than your typical six-inch screen not
all six-inch displays are created equal
a lot of people forget that the body is
now ceramic on the back and aluminum on
the sides so it's still that super shiny
fingerprinty slippery finish but is also
a bit heavier than normal phones of this
size so ceramic is a really dense
premium material like we talked about
with the essential phone and it's
packing that as well but really all the
placement of everything the buttons the
ports the speaker is all the same
because the body is smaller so that just
means everything is easier to reach the
only difference is just that they got
rid of the headphone jack this year so
essentially now that they have
everything from that original phone in a
smaller more compact more reasonable
size what they did was basically a
once-over of the entire phone to take
anything that was a little bit extreme
to make that original design happen and
bring it down to earth so that
piezoelectric speaker at the top of the
old phone that had to vibrate the whole
front of the device to make sound that's
replaced by an actual real front-facing
speaker and earpiece up at the top of
the phone much more practical
directional sound much more useful it
still has the ultrasonic proximity
sensor firing through the glass so
that's cool
and the selfie camera is still at the
bottom in the small chin but they coated
the glass in a slightly more polarized
shaded way so it kind of it's darker and
it sort of blends into the front of the
phone more and it's harder to see it's a
nice touch that adds to the seamless
feel of the phone and doesn't seem to
have any impact on the camera's
performance and they did upgrade the
camera on the back so it's now a 12
megapixel sony imx 386 sensor with
optical image stabilization
an f 2.0 aperture and still inside that
24 karat gold ring in the middle of the
back of the phone so no dual cameras on
the back of this guy again but it's
definitely an upgrade in the camera
department even if it's not quite to the
level of what samsung and apple are
doing right now and the fingerprint
reader on the back is also now
even faster like it's super fast now
which is confidence inspiring and of
course it's now in that ideal location
for one-handed use since the phone's
smaller and it's still in the middle of
the back and on the inside you have some
pretty op specs right now snapdragon 835
six gigs of ram up to 256 gigs of
storage and a 3 400 milliamp hour
battery so with all that refresh in the
hardware which is pretty impressive it
basically comes down to whether or not
you can stand the miui software on top
of android that rom
and they have added a bunch of new
things in these updates to make it more
accessible but more importantly more
familiar miui now has a split screen
multitasking mode so this is something
almost every phone now has except the
iphone where you can do two apps open at
once that's been added and it's pretty
simple to use and works well so you can
really take advantage of the big screen
honestly i'm kind of surprised it wasn't
on the original
there's still that quick ball that moves
the bottom row of shortcuts anywhere you
want on the display in case the corners
of the six inch panel are still kind of
hard to reach and it's overall cleaned
up it's pretty snappy it doesn't have
much bloat not many bloatware apps and
it's honestly already gotten one
software update since i've gotten the
thing out the box and hopefully it
continues to get more it's on top of
android 7.1.1 right now so pretty
standard for new phones coming out right
now but i think the benchmark is just
how fast they move to android 8.0 i'm
kind of having tabs on all the big
phones to see how fast they do it but
wait there's more there's also a meme
mix 2
special edition here it is actually next
to the standard mix 2. surely you can
tell the difference
or probably not the special edition
basically instead of rocking the matte
black aluminum sides has curved the
ceramic all the way over around to the
front so it's a ceramic unibody phone
which is actually kind of amazing and
then it also has eight gigs of ram so
that's what makes a special edition
super limited a little more expensive
hard to get also harder to grip that's
your call so a lot of changes that are
comfortable and make a lot of sense for
the mix too that i think they're hoping
will get people to go from drooling over
the mimics to actually buying one
obviously 2017 has been this year of of
disappearing bezels on the front of
smartphones i made an entire video about
that but i think the changes they're
making are more to just put it on a
global scale now this supports a massive
amount of bands 37 bands total 22 of
those being lte bands so the goal here
it has a dual sim card slot the goal is
that you can put your sim card in this
anywhere and it'll work including here
so to mix or not to mix that is the
question that i'll pass on to you guys
but either way that's pretty much it the
new iphone's right around the corner new
video on that coming very soon be sure
to subscribe to see that if you haven't
already until then catch you guys in the
next one talk to you later peace
[Music]